yeah so okay once I had one so bad that
I was like this is when I was in
residency and I was like it was just
driving me nuts so I went to the o R and
I got a bunch of lidocaine which is a
local anesthetic and I went into the
call room and I just grabbed my tongue
and just injected like lidocaine in it
just when I did that somebody walked in
and I've got like blood dripping down
from my mouth and I've got a needle in
my mouth and they're like and I'm like
no no no it's not what you think it's
not what you think I swear it's
lidocaine they're like dude oh we're
going to help you know who support
groups for people like you lidocaine is
disgusting I had my deviated septum
fixed and they shoved the lidocaine up
there you know it's it's it's harsh
stuff and the rest of the day I just
felt like shaky and just weird and then
I realized oh this is like a almost like
a cocaine type thing
like it's you know you know why we have
lidocaine because of cocaine yeah yeah
that's a guy named William Stewart
Halsted who was so near and dear to my
heart because he was the original he was
the founding surgeon at Johns Hopkins
and one of the original four horsemen so
the four main physicians that basically
have shaped medicine in this country all
started out at Hopkins Osler in medicine
Hopkins in surgery and two other guys
Walsh and I'm blinkin Kelly was the
third one and he basically figured out
because you got to remember like there
was a day when surgery was staggeringly
barbaric like prior to ether surgery was
like alright can you hold him down like
gag him get him drunk
gag him and like we're gonna do our
thing all right yeah it's just crazy so
god I used to know all of this [ __ ] I
don't remember any of the exact dates
anymore but it was like kind of like
mid-1800s to late 1800s when up at
Massachusetts General Hospital I forget
the name of who it was but someone
basically came up with ether so ether
became the first form of anaesthetic but
you know you were sort of knocking
people out well it was you know fast
forward probably 20-30 years when
Halsted figured out that this thing
called cocaine could provide local
anaesthetic so he began experimenting
with like crazy and of course in the
process became
like patently addicted to it so you have
this entire generation of surgeons at
Hopkins from that early era that were
completely coke addicted so Halsted in
all of his first generation of residents
and then of course from that we got
lidocaine bupivacaine all of these
things that don't have the same
properties
but to this day cocaine is still used
and most people don't realize it but
cocaine is a schedule 2 drug meaning it
actually has a medical application
unlike heroin which is Schedule one in
the DEA and marijuana that's right but
but cocaine is scheduled to and it is
still used in some ENT surgery because
it has some favorable properties over
even lidocaine and bupivacaine for nasal
surgery did you know that they still use
coca leaves for flavor in coca-cola they
actually extract the cocaine from it use
the coca leaves and the cocaine goes to
medical I had cocoa tea for my first
time this summer like real cocoa de
latte but like brought up from the Monta
Monta - cocoa that's what it is oh yeah
it's great I could not get enough of
that stuff you can't shut the [ __ ] up on
it though that's it's a weird sort of hi
it's a very strange thing it's very
talkative sort of hi I thought it was
just everything about it was like just
the leaves you ever done that like in
Peru or no no I've never done neither
but apparently it's really interesting
like the it's like a coffee sort of a
thing and it's got flavonoids it's
actually yeah yeah it's actually
probably healthy for you
I just love plants in general yeah but
what it's we think of the coca leaves as
producing cocaine cocaine we think of as
inherently negative but the leaf itself
like if you just don't extract it it's
actually really good
well that's the thing I mean I and that
you know even like thinking about the
difference between eating fruit versus
eating Oreos yeah like yeah like